where we laugh less where we left off in
the last video we had somewhat
simplified our polynomial p of x from
the way that it was originally described
in the problem but it still doesn't seem
like we're any closer to finding the
roots at least we were able to reduce
the degree from a 47th degree polynomial
to the product of a first degree and a
23rd degree polynomial but it still
doesn't seem like we are any closer to
finding the roots especially the roots
that matter and here we're going to have
to there's another little bit of an aha
moment here that this part this part in
blue which is really just the sum of all
of the degrees of x from x to the 0 all
the way to x to 23. this actually looks
a lot it is actually if you view the
common ratio as x as a finite geometric
series and i've done it in other videos
there is a way to find the sum of a
finite geometric series and we'll use a
similar technique right here to simplify
this a little bit to help us find the
root so let's just call this whole thing
s
so let's just call this s is equal to
x to the 23
plus x to the 22nd plus all the way down
to x plus one so that's this thing over
here now let's multiply
s times x so x times s
is going to be equal to and actually let
me do it like this because this will
help us a little bit i'm going to write
it up here and it's going to look a
little bit messy x times s is going to
be so
actually let me i'll just write it over
here x
times s is equal to
let me save some space actually
x times s is equal to
x times x to 23 is x to the 24th power x
times x to the 22nd is going to be x to
the 20
x to the 23rd power
and then x there's going to be an x to
the 21st when you multiply it by x
you're going to get x to the 22nd all
the way down to when you multiply
x times x you're going to get plus x
squared and then when you multiply the 1
times x you're going to get x
now what i want to do let's subtract
this from that
let's subtract it
let's subtract it i won't put the
negative sign out there so on the
left-hand side of the equation you have
s minus xs
so s minus xs is equal to what happens
on the right hand side of the equation
well you're going to have
this guy minus this guy these are going
to cancel out these are going to cancel
out everything is going to cancel out
except you're going to have a 1 minus x
to the 24th so you're going to have 1
minus x to the 24th now let's just
multiply both sides by negative 1
because this will just give it in a
slightly easier form for us so this is
the same thing if we multiply both sides
times negative 1 is xs
minus s is equal to x to the 24th minus
1. we can factor out an s here i'll do
it over here so if we factor out an s
from the left hand side we get s times x
minus 1
is equal to x to the 24th minus 1 or we
could say that the sum
the sum is equal to
x to the 24th minus 1 over x minus 1. so
this whole thing in blue over here can
be written can be rewritten as this
right over here is x to the 24th minus 1
over x to the minus x over x minus 1.
now let's be clear here
what we really care about for this
problem is to figure out the roots that
have
the roots whose squares have complex
parts we already we already know that
one of the roots is
zero because if you set this equal to
zero x could be equal to zero zero
squared is still zero does not have a
complex part so it really doesn't matter
so for our problem and the other thing
that we we wanna
keep in mind
is that we don't wanna double count
roots let's reread the problem a little
bit because what we're going to have is
a bunch of
i guess you could view them as double
roots you're going to have you're only
going to have 23 distinct distinct roots
from this part of the polynomial and
they say let z1 z2 and zr be the
distinct zeros the distinct zeros of p
sub x so what we only care about right
now are these 23 zeros we don't have to
think about those 23 zeros twice we're
not going to add their imaginary parts
twice so we can kind of substitute p of
x with
we really just care i'll just come up
let's call it q of x
let's call q of x we really just care
about the zeros of q of x which is just
x to the 23 plus x to the 22nd plus all
the way down to
x squared plus x plus 1. that's this
inside part the fact that it's squared
that just doubles the roots but we just
care about the distinct roots so we
really just care about the sum
of the imaginary part of the absolute
value of the imaginary parts of the
squares of the roots of this guy right
over here and we just figured out that
this guy can be rewritten as this over
here or
or even better let's
define let's define instead of defining
q of x like this let's define q of x as
this times
as this times x
as this times x let me let me write it a
little bit as this times x minus 1.
let's just define q of x here so this q
of x is going to have all of the same
distinct roots that matter as this p of
x but it's also going to have the root x
is equal to 1 which is clearly not a
root here if you put x equals one here
you're just gonna you're actually going
to get 24 so it's not going to be equal
to zero but what makes this better
easier to find the roots of is that this
thing right over here is equivalent to
it's equivalent to this part in yellow
is x to the 24th minus 1 over x
minus 1 times x minus 1
times x minus 1 which is equal to
x to the 24th minus 1. so we've
simplified the problem of actually draw
a huge amount what we've said is the
roots that we care about are actually
the roots of this polynomial right here
except for x is equal to 1. we just kind
of added that there to simplify it which
is equal to the roots of this polynomial
here except for 1 because we added 1 as
a root so we just care about the roots
of this polynomial except for 1. and the
roots of this polynomial are well i
won't say easy but it's a lot more
straight it's it's much more
straightforward to calculate
if we set this polynomial equal to 0
if we set it equal to 0 to figure out
the roots we just get x to the 24th add
one to both sides is equal to one so
we're going to have remember this is
going to have 24 roots one of them is
going to be one
we want to ignore the one so we care
about the 23 non-one roots and we care
about squaring them and then taking the
absolute value of their imaginary parts
so we essentially need to think about
the all of the 24th roots of one and
then ignore one so let's think about how
to do that a little bit and this is
going to delve a little bit into complex
into complex into the complex plane
so just as a refresher how do we find
all of the all of the roots of one the
24th roots of one and just remember we
can rewrite one so let's draw a little
complex plane over here
so let's draw a complex plane
so this is this is the real axis and
this is the
imaginary axis one is sitting right over
here it only has a real part it is one
but we know that we can rewrite this we
can rewrite one
we can rewrite one as
as let me write it this way it could be
e
to the i
times 0 actually anything so this is e
to the 0 obviously equal to 1 or we can
add 2 pi to it if we're dealing with
radians so 1 is equal to e to the i0
which is also equal to e
to the 2 pi i which but you can keep
adding because if you add 2 pi it goes
around the complex plane once if you add
another 2 pi it goes around again so
it's also plus it also equals
it also equals e to the 4 pi
i it also equals e to the 6 pi
e to the 6 pi i it also equals e to the
8 pi i think you get the general idea so
if you want to find the 24th roots you
want to just raise all of these things
to the 20 to the 1 over 24
1 over 24. so essentially you're going
to take this divide by 24 divide by 24
divide by 24 divide by 24 divide by 24
and then keep going you can actually go
all the way well i'll depict it over
here so what is this first root the
first root is e to the zero over 24
that's just e to the zero that's just
one that's the root that we can ignore
right because we added that root to q of
x to simplify a little bit now what's
this root over here
what's this root over here this is e to
the pi over 12 i e to the pi over 12 i
which remember is the same thing as
cosine of pi over 12 that's the real
part plus i sine of pi over 12
i sine of pi over 12. and if we were to
draw that we would have an angle of pi
over 12 and if you wanted to think in
degrees that would be 15 degrees so it
would look something like this
it would look something like this
right over here so we do care about that
root right over here now what would this
root be well this root is going to be pi
over 6 it's going to have twice the
angle so it's going to look like this
so this root right here is going to look
like this
this root over here
and notice they're pi over 12 apart
this root over here this is pi over so
six this is pi over four so it's going
to look like this pi over 4 that's 45
degrees so it's going to look
like this so notice each of the roots
we're just adding
are just multiples of this for i
shouldn't say multiples our powers of
this first root over here we're just
increasing the degree by pi over 12. and
remember we just care about the
imaginary parts of their squares so
let's just first of all just think about
the roots that matter
so one way to think about it is we could
literally just draw a unit circle here
and divide it into 24 sections so let me
draw that
let me draw it
a little bit let me redraw a little bit
so i don't overload this graph over here
actually i'm running out of time in this
video i might continue it in the next
so we could draw a unit circle here
they're all going to have magnitude one
so we're going to have we could draw a
unit circle over here
one of the roots is one but we're going
to have 24 roots so we can draw we can
divide it into 24 sections so we have
four sections right here each of them
we're going to have six roots in each
section so we're going to have one pi
over 12
2 pi over 12 pi over 4 and then you have
the one symmetric to that then you have
the one symmetric to that let me make
sure i'm doing this right you're going
to have the divi and then you're going
to have and then you're going to have pi
over 2. so these are the roots that are
actually let me just continue this in
the next video i don't wanna when i
start rushing this is kind of a new
concept anyway i'll continue this in the
next video